C'est le moment de l'intro nul, Bonjour !
Aujourd'hui on est à ...
J'me sens pas naturel du tout *rire*
On va voir à l'intérieur comment c'est ?
Electronic Art m'envoie à l'ESA (Agence spatiale européenne)
Pour suivre un entrainement d'astronaute à l'occasion de la sortie de ''Mass Effect Andromeda''.
Bon dans le jeu bien sur, ils ont des technologies bien plus avancées que nous actuellement,
Mais cela n'empêche qu'ils sont dans l'espace et aujourd'hui on va faire ce p*tain d'entrainement que les astronautes font
Avant d'aller dans l'espace, et croyez-moi ... Il est lourd.
Mais avant ça, on va faire un petit tour de l'endroit.
J'arrive Thomas (Thomas Pesquet)
Je t'aime mon amour <3
*Musique*
Les amis, c'est ouf ! On est dans une reproduction d'un module de l'ISS (Station spatiale internationale)
Un reproduction fidèle, c'est à dire que quand tu va vraiment à l'ISS, y'a un p*tain de module qu'est exactement comme ça !
On a par exemple ici une transition vers un autre module.
Donc eux ils y vont en volant, nous on y va à pied comme des m*rdes.
On est sur une station spatiale, mais en fait vu que les modules ont été envoyés dans l'espace y'a des dizaines d'années,
On voit que c'est un peu vieillit
Tsé, au niveau de la gueule que ça a *rire*
Tu pensais que c'était un truc futuriste de ouf avec des hologrammes, c'est faux ! Retour à la réalité
En fait ici on est dans le hall d'entrainement donc c'est plein de reproductions de modules comme ici.
Et les astronautes viennent ici pendant des années, s'entrainer à faire des actions qu'ils vont refaire là-haut, mais sur la vraie ISS, dans des vrais modules !
Donc ils ont pas le  droit à l'erreur, ils ont un entrainement de malade mental, y'a un cycle en fait d'entrainement
Pour devenir astronaute, tu dois être sélectionné
Ensuite tu va continuer de d'entrainer pendant entre une et cinq années
Et ensuite, il faut qu'ils aient une mission pour toi en fait, une mission à te donner.
Et quand ils préparent une mission, ils créent un équipage. Thomas Pesquet j'crois qu'il était avec un américain et un Japonais (Russe)
Et lui il s'est entrainé pendant 5 ans ici avant de partir donc le mec j'pense qu'il s'est tout faire actuellement.
Tu lui donne un caillou, il te fabrique un pc, c'est sur.
Et c'est des missions de 6 mois, donc il faut se dire que les astronautes vont passer 6 mois dans des trucs aussi étroits enfaite dans l'espace.
Ils ont quand même des balls quoi p*tain moi j'y arriverais pas. Franchement c'est super oppressant.
Donc ils font leurs missions, ils reviennent sur terre. Ils repassent en mode entrainements réguliers jusqu'à qu'on leur ré-attribue une nouvelle mission,
Qu'on les ré-intègrent dans un nouvelle équipage, d'ailleurs qui peut être le même que leur précédant. Et qu'ils repartent.
Voilà c'est l'histoire d'un(e) astronaute. Ce que Thomas Pesquet est en train de vivre aujourd'hui finalement.
Les amis on a trouvé le poste de simulation de pilotage de Soyouz.
En fait pendant des années ils s'entrainent et ils s'entrainent notamment à conduire le truc qui va leur permettre d'atteindre l'ISS,
C'est bien de s'entrainer mais si ils arrivent pas à atteindre l'ISS, bah ça sert pas à grand chose.
*S'installe dans la machine*
J'espère qu'ils fixent le siège avant de partir.
Ah ouais, c'est des joy-sticks, mais en fait je suis trop en arrière.
Ça c'est pour tes avant-bras, et tu fais ça avec tes petits pouces. Tu fais ton p'tit créneau comme ça.
Après comme on est habitués aux jeux vidéos, tu vois ... on pourra rejoindre l'ISS.
Eh mec ! T'es trop bien là ! Comment ils s'endorment pas ? Ah oui, parce qu'ils ont 18G dans la gueule !
Tu pense Thomas il conduisait ? Ou alors il jouait à Dofus sur l'écran qu'est là ? Y'a un écran avec une p'tite souris là.
J'me casse sur l'ISS, au revoir. * fermeture de la porte*
*Musique*
Ici c'est le poste Eurocom, donc le communicateur Européen, et le but du "jeu" pour le Eurocom,
C'est d'être la voix de l'équipe, la FlyControlTeam, l'équipe de vol sur terre, qui s'occupe du module Européen Colombus.
Dès qu'il y a quelque chose qui se passe dans Colombus, y'a un Eurocom qui va être là pour transmettre les informations,
Recevoir *voix microphone*
Squeezie : Comme ce qu'il se passe actuellement ?
Romain : Voila c'est ça, y'a Peggi qui vient d'appeller
Squeezie :T'entends les informations en direct ?
Romain : Là c'est en direct.
C'est incroyable. Et donc là les images des astronautes, c'est aussi en direct ?
Merci pour tout, c'était super de t'avoir parlé, quelqu'un qui parle français, ça m'a fais super plaisir.
Et en plus c'est hyper intéressant, c'est que les stars sont souvent des l'espace mais en fait y'a autant de stars au sol,
Ici qui les aident, et qui les assistent et qui préparent ce voyage avec eux, Bah bravo pour ce que tu fait, Bravo, Bonne continuation. Prend soin de notre Thomas
Romain : Merci
Squeezie : Prends soin de notre Thomas
Avec Plaisir
Les amis c'est ouf, on est devant une piscine de 10 mètres de profondeur,
Dans laquelle se trouve une reproduction du module Colombus. Ils vont là dedans en tenue d'astronaute et en fait, ça simule une vraie sortie dans l'espace.
C'est la simulation la plus proche de la vraie situation. On arrive pas à créer un espace ou il n'y a pas de gravité sur terre, c'est impossible
Donc on fait ça sous l'eau, et ça les entraine de ouf, et ils vont répéter, répéter, répéter les mêmes mouvements encore et encore
Pour que le jour où ils le fassent pour de vrai dans l'espace, ça ne foire pas.
On va se changer pour faire la plongée. Ma combinaison d'homme qui va aller dans l'espace sous l'eau.
C'est trop cool, c'est collector.
Arrêtez, cassez-vous !
J'me transforme en astronaute. RPZ (représente) la France. En plus, ils mettent ça mais une fois dans l'ISS, ils sont en mode T-Shirt blanc et  p'tit Jogging gris t'sé Nike
Ah ! Pardon. Très important !
Ah le Yiot Club, ça à vraiment plus rien à voir
On va pas mettre ça ?
Je suis fier d'être Français. J'vais bien représenter notre pays, le mec qui va mourir noyé, ça sera moi
Allez let's go, j'crois qu'on va nous briffer avant de plonger, ce qui est selon moi un peu nécessaire.
Bonjour !
Squeezie : Comment ça va ?
Hervé : Bonjour
Squeezie : Comment t'appelle tu ?
Hervé
Squeezie : Hervé que fais-tu ici ?
Ici, je suis l'instructeur pour les agents de l'Agence Spatiale Européenne,
Pour les sorties extraniculaire (?) dehors dans l'espace, et depuis cette salle de contrôle, puisqu'on va t'entrainer,
Je gère les opérations et je m'assure que tout se passe bien
Squeezie : Tu as des yeux partout
Hervé : Exactement, et je suis comme l'astronaute dans la station spatiale
Qui vérifie que ses copains à l'extérieur fassent du bon boulot.
Squeezie : Ça marche à trois du coup, nous on va etre 2 à sortir et toi tu va etre celui qui controle le truc à distance,
Qui voit si on fait tout bien et qui en cas de pépin peut nous aider.
Exactement, j'peut vous aider
Squeezie : Tu nous as préparé un petit exercice du coup tu m'a dis c'est ça ?
Hervé : Oui tout à fait, on va aller voir ça, c'est juste à  coté.
Allez j'te suis, 'fin du coup tu me suis.
Squeezie : 10 mètres de profondeur !
Hervé : C'est là qu'on émerge les maquettes.
Squeezie : Donc nous on va pas descendre à 10 mètres de profondeur ?
Hervé : Non. Vous allez descendre pas trop profond, vous serez quand même immergés,
Pour des raisons de sécurité, car vous n'avez pas eu la formation préliminaire.
Mais on va aller voir les activités qui t'attendent et se que tu va devoir faire.
Squeezie : Ah ! On va faire du bon travail.
Squeezie : Voici le poste de travail ?
Hervé : exactement.
Donc comme un astronaute dans l'espace, vous allez devoir installer un équipement qui est en fait une expérience avec une antenne
Comme une antenne radar pour regarder environnement extérieur.
Et cette boite, vous allez devoir l'amener, l'installer ici,
Squeezie : L'accrocher avec les petits verrous qu'il y a ici
Hervé : L'ouvir, sans toucher les radiateur au dessuus,
Faire des connections électriques,
Squeezie : D'accord ! Et donc c'est le taff' que les astronautes font ?
Hervé : Exactement.
Hervé : Et ensuite y'aura une antenne, que vous allez installer au dessus,
Squeezie : Oké on l'installe dedans, ça marche
Hervé : Il va falloir la fixée pour éviter quelle s'envole, pour la fixer vous aller devoir utiliser des outils
Du coup tout est attachées, puis qu'on est sous l'eau, donc forcément sa vole si on l'attache pas
Vérifier que la configuration est bonne
Hervé : mettre la puissance
Squeezie : s'écarter Hervé : a ce moment la vous vous écartez
Hervé : on met tout en route, on reçoit la clef de mesure et tout va bien
Squeezie : Purééée! On vas être des héros aujourd'hui !
Et ! Donc ! la difficulté c'est que pour faire tous ça
Voici ton pire ennemi !
Un gant euhh... qui fait que  t'as des doigts qui font
trois fois la taille de tes doigts normalement et du coup
manipuler avec sa c'est très très dur en fait!
on a essayés juste avant et c'est un calvaire !
mais j'pense que sa vas l'faire on vas y arriver! t'a confiance en moi Hervé ?
Hervé : mais ta réussis a l'faire.., j'ai confiance en toi
Squeezie : Bhé, voila ! Hervé a confiance, du cou j'ai confiance ne moi aussi! je suis en train d'enfiler
ma seconde peau qui vas me permettre
*...* de pénétré dans l'bassin !
Hyper oppréssant ! .. t'es vraiment comme sa :
Thomas, j'pense fort a toi par c'que j'ai le caleçon
qui rentre dans les fesses j'peut dire que c'est très désagréable
Allez, c'est parti ! c'est le moment d'y aller
j'vais pouvoir parler avec David, mon pote Espagnol qui fait la mission
avec moi, dans mon masque en fait c'est connectés et on est
aussi au truc de contrôle, juste là
Ou, notre troisième poto
vas nous donner les instructions si on les oublies !
*Musique triste* ( gros vent )
*Musique épique*
Les ami(es) je viens de sortir ...de l’expérience, de la mission qui a sauver la Terre
Apparemment
Il y avait Stefan et Hervé qui me parlais dans.. dans le masque
et en faite on entend assez bien sauf quand on expire on entend plus rien du tout !
Et du coup quand il me parlais j'devais arrêter de respirer
Ensuite pendant 20 secondes j'respirais comme un gros porc  et la on me parlais je pouvais pas ne pas respirer sinon j'mourrais
Et 2éme difficulté tu peux pas voir ce qu'il y a en dessous de toi
A un moment je me suis accrochet à David, j'ladore.
Mais.. j'ai pas fais exprès j'pensais que c'était son mousqueton et que j'lai arrangé en lui rendant mais enfaite c'était le mien
Mais c'était une expérience incroyable
C'était ouf!!
Et on se rend compte de la difficulté du truc mais c'est dur, mais c'était c'est
Hervé: mais c'est que le début Squeezie: et c'est que le début !!
Mission réussi ! Merci chef ! C'était génial !
Bah merci ! Ça me fait très plaisir !
Allez maintenant on va allez se changer, on va se sécher  et.. et on va dormir
Avant de commencer l'entraînement j'vous présente la DLR, c'est le bâtiment de l'agence spatial allemande !
C'est dans ce bâtiment qu'on va faire l'entraînement d'aujourd'hui enfaite, c'est surtout un bâtiment de recherches médicales
J'vais sortir d'ici car ça me mets mal a l'aise
Donc ici il font pas mal d'expériences , ils ont un laboratoire physiologique , un laboratoire psychologique, un laboratoire biologique , les mecs ils bombardent dans tout ce qui est études
Donc derrière nous c'est des centrifugeuses qu'ils ont mis au point vu que leurs corps n'est pas soumis à la gravité
Et ben leurs muscles s'atrophient finalement il y a pleins de truc qui ne fonctionne plus comme quand ton corps est soumis à la gravité
Et du coup ils essayent d'entretenir sa tant bien que mal mais le blém c'est que quand tu cours et quand tu fais du sport
T'as quand même des muscles qui ne sont pas solliciter et ton corps modifie ses manières de fonctionner
Et à long termes ils aimeraient mettre sa dans l'ISS dans la station spatial international pour enfaite simuler la gravité grâce à la force de la centrifugeuse et sa permet a tout ces petits muscles
qui ne sont pas solliciter malgré le fait qu'ils fassent 2h de sport et ben de bien se porter
Et comme sa leur retour sur Terre serait moins douloureux !
Et maintenant on va arrêter de parler et on va allez s'entrainer !
(truc étrange mdr)
WWOOOW la ça va vite mon gars !
Je refait plus jamais !!
Alors la les ami(es) on va tester le sport de façon astronaute !
Comme ils font là-haut
Y'a des élastiques qui les maintiennes vers un tapis
Enfaite il y a pas de gravité
C'est des élastiques qui maintiennes vers un tapis
Il m'as pris pour un allemand j'ai pas compris du tout ce qu'il a dit !
Et sa tire de ouf sur les jambes mon gars !
La j'vais a 5km\H
Sa flingue les jambes mec c'est chaud de ouf
Comment on dit "je suis en train de mourrir"en allemand ?
J'crois vraiment ça fais les muscles 3 fois plus que sur un tapis normal
J'ai envie d’arrêter j'en peux plus !
Outch, sa ma flinguer le cul un truc de ouf !
Mec, j'peux plus marcher quoi !
Je suis mort aha
Détacher moi !!
Laisser moi rentrer chez moi s'il vous plaît !!
C'était bien toute cette expérience mais là
Y s'en bat les couilles , il aurait pus me casser une dent
Allez on s'en vas d'ici , j'en peux plus moi de l'espace et tout, la j'en peux plus, j'tiens plus
*musique outro*